[Music]
what's up guys thanks for tuning into
the podcast this week it's all about
this guy named eye Delgado check this
dude out we spent most of this podcast
talking about his protein deficiency
right yeah we talked about oh man we
went through the whole the whole story
from start to beginning so if you want
to learn more about where I come from my
whole message my bodybuilding and
nutrition strategies we touched on
everything and much more too right I
forgot to mention he's a vegan
professional bodybuilder plant-based
athlete advocate absolute beast
beautiful guy and we had a great
conversation so hope you guys enjoy
let's do this man alright knee my in the
house man so nice to meet you delighted
to have you here today thank you so much
for having me man I'm actually really
really excited to be here cool man
awesome this this is a long time coming
there's a lot of people excited about
this and just to kind of kick it off I
wanted to say publicly like I'm just
such a huge fan of who you are what
you're doing the way that you're
carrying the message and I think it's
incredibly powerful and I've said this
many times before but it's one thing for
a guy like me who's the skinny endurance
athlete to go and you know talk about
the things that I care about and it's
another thing altogether when it's a guy
like you because you're I mean for
people that are just listening on their
iPhones or their mobile devices and not
watching this on YouTube you should
watch it on YouTube to get a glimpse of
what this guy's all about cuz you are
absolutely jack you have one of the most
incredible physiques I've ever seen and
when somebody who's so strong who is so
ripped is speaking about the things that
I've been shouting from the mountaintops
for a long time I think it has the
potential to land in a very different
way and I think that that that is a very
potent way of spreading this message and
I applaud you for kind of taking that
mantle and running with it so to speak
wow that was like incredibly humbling to
hear so I just want to say thank you for
I mean the super nice words and even can
me to have on the show because I've been
listening you for quite some time now so
it's like like you said it's a long time
coming and I've been manifesting it for
quite a while so it's awesome you were
yeah all in all in I've learned to like
trust timing on these things they happen
when they're they're supposed to happen
yeah I can play it's a good time you
know here we are you were recently on
the cover of Muscle & Fitness yes so
that's that's a huge deal to be on the
cover of that magazine as you know vegan
or not vegan and also we're kind of as
far as I know or on the cusp of the
game-changer of movie coming out I'm do
when is that is there a date yet for the
release of that if I had a dollar for
every time somebody asked me I wish I
know yeah the moment I know everybody
else is gonna know cuz I'll be the first
one to be posing it all over social
media but yeah I can just say that it's
worth the wait right cool so yeah I
haven't seen the movie yet but I know
that you figure prominently in that for
good reason so let's tell your story
dude you have a really interesting back
story about how all of this began yeah
that goes back to Argentina yeah I guess
it does I guess it does uh I'll just go
back to the beginning from the very
beginning so my heritage is Argentinian
both of my parents were born and raised
in Buenos Aires Argentina came from you
know primarily Catholic families went
through the whole system and my mom
actually I guess she's the catalyst to
this whole story coming about when she
was about I don't 15 or so she had a
very public boyfriend he was like the
vice president's son or at I don't know
the exact story but they owned a ranch
and she went over one day and basically
he slaughtered a pig in front of her and
she was kind of traumatized by it as a
15 16 year old would be and made a
decision right then that she wouldn't
ever eat or touch meat again
and yeah she just kind of lived her life
from 15 on and that was it like she just
it wasn't like it wasn't just in words
only like she actually lived up to that
know yeah exactly if you knew my mom
she's probably the most compassionate
person I've selfless person I've ever
met in my life and I'm not just saying
that
I'm a mama's boy like I really do
believe that and uh yeah so my grandpa
he was definitely apprehensive whenever
she decided to give up meat for many
reasons that you and I hear every single
day
yeah well Argentina's a big meat culture
yeah it's a big part of culture and just
being social I would imagine
yeah and they're very like five aja spew
Argentinians you cannot wait I can
always spot one from a crowd or if it's
a group of Latino people on a talk show
like you know you can always spot the
Argentinian because they're so loud
they're so full of energy they're they
talk with their hands they're all like
pedal chain you know like my grandpa was
a prime example of that so as you can
say as you can see or probably expect
like she got a lot of slack for it a lot
of I guess you know feedback from her
friends family and concern but as luck
would have it somewhere along the line
she was introduced to another lifestyle
and that was through the form of
Hinduism mm-hmm so at that time I guess
it must have been went late 70s early
80s Hinduism was getting a little bit
more westernized I don't know if you
remember that time or not I was I was
born in 89 so yeah yeah in college when
you were born okay yeah yeah so I don't
know what it was like in Argentina but
yeah me either but I think just
basically in a general sense being more
open to Eastern perspectives about
spirituality in general yeah yeah I mean
it was very small culture still at the
time back then
and she really resonated with a lot of
the kind of the core beliefs of Hinduism
and she still does and one of those
beliefs was that you know you don't eat
meat
she basically the hymns that yeah
exactly a hymns of the concept of do no
harm live live a life of not causing any
suffering any harm but also she almost
basically renounced all material things
as well and devoted herself fully to
service to God and went to a Hindu
temple and started living only in the
temple and that's kind of you know the
love story that happened between her and
my dad and they
so he was a renunciant also yes yeah for
different reasons like robes in the
whole thing oh yeah oh yeah like
literally no money begging for your food
kind of thing necessarily begging for
you relying on the generosity of
strangers yeah basically selling books
that was their way of making money they
were selling versions of the Bhagavad
Gita in the streets and they would have
a stack of books I'd go and sell them in
the streets of Argentina try to convince
somebody it'd try to convince probably
the most stake heavy eating country to
go vegetarian and come or maybe switch
over be open-minded to another religion
entire lease kind of like how you see
the Hari Krishna's they actually is the
Hari Krishna's that's a tribe that they
went into yeah yes she had the orange
robes yeah she cut her hair off and all
that she didn't my dad did that's what
the men do that Wow
so that my man had so your grandfather
must have been really freaking you oh
yeah my grandfather's a super
conservative too he's an airline pilot
Navy guy so I mean you could you could
you could just imagine what she had to
go through and what he thought whenever
she told him she's like hey I'm I'm
leaving to go join this Hari Krishna
movement right and basically devote
myself to God and yeah that's kind of a
love story that happened between her and
my dad they met fell in love had my
sister who was born in Argentina and
just kind of lived that way for a
certain number of years but then things
in Argentina were a little bit
tumultuous so they didn't feel like it
was the best environment to raise their
children and you know the universe would
have it they went from a temple in
Argentina to a temple in Brazil mm-hmm
in florianópolis had my brother in
Brazil and we're all two years apart
so they lived there for a few years
right on the beach was I see pictures of
it and it was just a beautiful place but
yeah like you're saying all bald my dad
was all bald
they wrote of the temple they had like a
little vegetarian restaurant at the time
that they were trying to you know keep
you know sustain their lifestyle and
everything and then as luck would have
it their spiritual guru mentioned an
opportunity to provide them with housing
and a place to live in America so my dad
was like I'll do it I'll go we've you
know the American Dream is something
that
known all around the world and my dad
basically went by himself didn't know
how to speak any English went to landed
in Miami started working as a taxi
driver to get enough money essentially
to move or to send back to my mom so she
could have a plane ticket to come then
that happened and my mom came with
basically two and a half kids so she was
pregnant with me pregnant with you ya
were born in the States
yeah I'm the gringo of the family that's
what they call me gringo basically the
only American born here and ended up in
Miami in the late 80s wasn't there's a
lot going on in Miami at that time so
they ended up going to Central Florida
to another temple in Alachua and then
right outside of Gainesville then went
to New Orleans because they heard about
another opportunity their first day in
New Orleans got their car stolen so they
were like to America yeah so they're
like yeah maybe New Orleans a little bit
too crazy for us so they ended up having
another they're like come on we already
gave away all our worldly possessions
like the car from their perspective it
wasn't too much of an issue of their
inconvenience right they weren't too
attached to anything at that time but
they were trying to provide their kids
essentially with a better opportunity
than they had yeah and there was another
temple in Mississippi in south
Mississippi and I'm gonna paint a
picture for you it's in the middle of
nowhere the middle of the Bible Belt and
essentially it's it was a dirt road and
they had a big like a big sign in the
front that said welcome to new telephone
basically International Society of
Krishna consciousness this is one of
their temples one of their farms and
that's where I was born and raised Wow
yeah so was it like a commune Kim um not
necessarily but everybody that lived
within the perimeter of the farm were
Hindu right so it's a pretty well-known
establishment within the community so
this faith-based community essentially
Hari Krishna's this is this is the this
is the environment in which you're weird
yes deep in the cell yeah yeah exactly
Wow essentially I tell people all the
time is just a bubble like I lived in a
bubble are you talking about being
raised in a bubble and not being a very
unique different
yeah yeah thank so that's where I grew
up the first about six years of my life
so every day I'd wake up 5:00 a.m. go to
the temple with my mom I would be
dressed head-to-toe in traditional
clothing I would wear the the tea lock
on my forehead I'd wear I still wear
neck beads we'd go to the temple we
chant mantra mantras and I lived in this
like really cool little environment I
mean it was it was essentially it was a
cow rescue sanctuary as well so they
would rescue cows from different farms
in the vicinity and it was like in hims
a farm so they wouldn't drink milk and
have key and make yogurt and all these
different things but from the cows that
were treated with love respect and and
everything else and we also had like a
garden like a community garden that was
like almost self-sustaining so they
would have like feasts every day they
would make food for the for the
community members and every Sunday they
would have a Sunday feast and it was
welcomed to everybody just like most
temples around the world anybody can
come and have food on Sundays that's why
yeah that's like its own little blue
zone
yeah Sencha Lee you know essentially and
what was when you would venture outside
the perimeter of the farm into the local
townships I mean how are you guys
received and and treated by the normal
people that were living in the
environment it was always like do you
remember candy yeah vividly vividly I
mean the place where we were living I
mean we were well known within the
outside community of who we were and we
were weird in those harde Krishna's and
their beliefs and you know their rituals
or whatever they would call any is very
foreign to the culture down there so we
would go out and my we would venture out
to the to the to the real world
essentially and I mean it was it was
different
receptions from people I mean I remember
vividly whenever I was a little kid that
waking up to a burning cross outside of
one of my friend's house and essentially
it was members of you know the I guess I
would assume the KKK you know I mean
that's unfortunately still alive and
real and racism's of real things still
to this day you know so it wasn't it was
challenging I'll say that yeah
I mean it's it's quite different for a
community like that to to find a
community like that like in let's say
like Big Sur or you know an environment
in which you kind of you're not that
surprised you know but in the deep deep
south that's a whole thing yeah
different altogether oh definitely is I
mean it's its own little bubble like I
was mentioning but that was until I was
like six so my parents being the the
kind of free thinkers that they are they
wanted me to have more opportunities so
they saw other kids that were being
raised in that environment that maybe
they were living more of a very humble
faith-based life and they wanted us to
get a proper education so they
assimilated me into public school right
and I went to public school at a very
young age I remember like my first days
at school I would go to school with the
markings with the necklaces and this is
this is the way my parents think my god
she'll be fine but she tossed me in the
water and said sink or swim right so and
how old were you I was kindergarten
through through the rest of high school
uh-huh
so I was like I'm a southerner like it
doesn't something you don't have an
accent
oh I fought it oh you bought it yeah I
mean my parents speak Spanish within the
household but I never felt like I
belonged essentially like I was saying I
lived in a bubble so I was like I don't
know surprising that that's how you felt
I mean I would imagine even in
kindergarten having some awareness of
just being very different from everyone
else yeah I mean it was it was made
apparent to me very quickly so were you
were you what kind of kid were you were
you bullied as a kid were you a quiet
kid were you an okay did you play sports
definitely a quiet kid I was always an
observer my grandpa used to call me the
philosopher because I wouldn't really
talk that much I was very observant but
when I did speak it was like something
profound or something with like some
thought behind it so we don't you to be
the next guru
yes actually essentially so I would
always you know I would I just kind of
accepted from a very early start that I
was different and accepted the fact that
not everybody was raised the way I was
raised because it was made apparent to
me
so I understood that kids were gonna
have their judgments on me they were
gonna say things to me and I you know to
this day I asked my parents I was like
what did you teach me as a kid
to not be tempted to kind of rebel or
you know just be one of the other kids
and just like adopt that lifestyle and
they were like we just taught you to to
love yourself love who you are
respect other living beings and we just
kept reinforcing it and we trusted in
you and we knew that you had understood
from an early age that that was the way
that we lived and you know we don't eat
animals and I just kind of like knows
like how that makes sense right yeah it
is wild that you didn't have that
impulse to rebel like it would have been
very the predictable course would have
been to say screw this man like you know
I'm out of here I want to be you know
the peer pressure I mean as a parent
with I got a fourteen-year-old daughter
of two older boys like I I know how
intense that can be to conform and to
fit into the flow of society and to be
able to have the emotional wherewithal
to to remain true to what you felt was
your North Star instilled by your
parents I mean that takes a certain
level of self-awareness and
self-confidence yeah I mean it's
developed over time like things test you
like just like anything in life people
will pick and prod and kids can be
really cruel I'll just say that kids can
be really cruel I don't know how many
times I've had even when I was growing
up I'd bring my lunch obviously and you
know I'd open up my lunch box and here
they are I grew up on Indian food too
right both my parents were really good
chefs RJ I don't know if I grew up on
Argentinian the vegetarian food or
Indian food essentially essentially yes
live there no no no I'll get to that
yeah sorry
so essentially I'd opened up my lunch
box and like I mean the flavors that
Indian food contained cumin turmeric all
of these things are curry all these
things are very have a very strong odor
to them so I'd open up my lunch box and
immediately the first thing everybody
would say would be
like like what is that like what are you
eating me my and I'd be like no no my
parents cooked it and I'm just gonna eat
it and they would always like put
burgers in my face chicken nuggets all
this stuff they serve it you know in
high school in elementary school and be
like oh I'll give you a dollar to eat it
or just try it and I never really
understood that like why somebody would
get so much joy out of me doing what
they wanted me to do so I kind of almost
like made a stance against it I was like
now I'm just I'm not gonna do it to
almost prove a point and just stay true
to who I was and that kind of helped me
build up that strength and that
confidence that like I am Who I am
take it or leave it and at the same time
still wanting to be accepted so I ended
up becoming a chameleon you know I
learned how to deflect really easily and
really early on so when people would ask
me at birthday parties you know why
aren't you eating hotdogs I would just
say I just don't like him you know and I
would just make make Dorito sandwiches
so I could like do pieces of bread so
I'm like cheddar cheese and put some
Doritos on it and that would be my meal
when I go to like birthday parties and
stuff and even and so other social
situations where parents would come up
to me they'd be like the NEMA are you
hungry let me cook for you and I just
like I hated that pressure of being
different and being like a nuisance so
somebody had to like go the extra mile
just to provide for me so I just like
now you know I'm fine like I'm I'm just
okay I only have chips but still
maintaining that boundary you know I
would think like a small child after a
while you're like fine you know and also
this idea of you like this sense that
you have of this is who I am this is
this is my set of core values did you
ever have a reckoning like a moment
where you're like wait a minute are
these my core values or are these just
the values that I've always known
because my parents were impressing them
upon me like is this what I believe or
is this just what I've been told my
whole life mm-hmm I think everybody goes
to that at some point in their life at
least those who do reflection find
themselves at that position and that
crossroads is like am I Who I am or am I
who I was told to be right but for me I
I I really did believe that it made
sense like I'm a logical person
it all made logical sense you know like
when I was younger if I was presented
with a few situations in front of me if
I had an apple or like a you know a baby
chicken
I wouldn't rip his head open and start
eating the baby chicken I would just
reach for the Apple so that same concept
kind of can be extrapolated and just
because you're not the one that's you
know taking the animal's life doesn't
mean the life isn't taken so it just
made sense you know I just kind of
thought of it logically like that yeah
that's interesting I think a lot of
people sort of just think well you know
that that chicken breast is already has
already been killed and it's been boned
and it's in the packaging at the grocery
store so does it really matter whether I
buy it or not because it's already there
and somebody's gonna buy it like and
it's easier to kind of be in denial or
not you know solve that mathematical
equation about where your duck what your
dollars are contributing to yeah in a
sense but I mean not all life is
determined by dollars and cents I mean
if luckily I was raised from like a car
may expect 'iv too so that's kind of
where I understood that I'm you know I
believe I'm not this body you know it's
just a vessel for me and one day I might
be in that that chickens body so I
wouldn't like that to happen to me so
why would I do it to it when I'm
completely fine living without it you've
come this far
yeah backwards yeah that cycle right
yeah exactly so I you know the concept
of a hit hymns at Karma all these things
they add up over time and I figured if I
can just refrain from contributing to it
because even by buying a package chicken
breast you basically pay someone that's
sitting in an office that is their job
to think how can we kill more animals
more efficiently how can we extract from
them more products and you're paying
that person so yeah you still contribute
to the you know the suffering and
everything else yeah so never eaten meat
in your entire life never not on purpose
I've never have that one time I can
recall where I ate it or I didn't like
in my mouth on accident was I was in
Taco Bell and got it I used to get a you
see Taco Bell
right like bean and cheese burritos
cheese quesadillas and I ordered a
cheese quesadilla bit into it
immediately noticed the texture
difference was like chunky and I just
spit it out immediately I started like
getting like nauseous and it's just like
the thought of that just like kind of
reinforced that I wasn't for me you know
so that was that was probably when I was
in like ninth grade or so so you know
I've had moments where me and that's not
the only you know scenario where it's
something like that's happened but and
I'm sure somewhere along the line maybe
I've accidentally consumed it and just
completely unaware of it but I just
don't think I like I consider my body
like I try to keep it as pure as
possible and just just refrain from it
right so high school rolls around you're
still living in the community no no no
so so it's moved out of when I was about
seven years old
and we moved to a more traditional
southern community yeah I mean I wore
normal like I went back home I don't
know what I said to my parents whenever
I was younger but I was like just just
dress me normally you know and because
my sister was like she was four years
older than me so she was dealing with it
on another level because because she was
also the white Spanish speaking Hindu
person with a weird name so I mean
there's a lot of different things happen
in there to stand out so she was like I
just want to blend in just put me in
normal clothes and I was the same way
just put me in normal clothes and I'll
assimilate right and you have it and
your brother's older than you as well
yeah my brother's too nice
so they were kind of like the Canaries
in the coal mine out there like you know
this is wasted testing yeah so by the
time you become of age like your parents
sort of figure out like okay like we do
that yeah right and my sister's very
vocal too so I'm sure she let them know
immediately like you need to stop this
what did they do now so my sister
ironically she works for cardiologists
as a echo technician so she'll do heart
scans my parents they have their own
businesses as well as my brother and I'm
out here in California just kind of
figuring out life yeah so so when when
you're in high school are you playing
sports
we are you athletic yeah
I've always been athletic like I grew up
and naturally I played soccer when I was
younger I was like the young Argentine I
had long hair too so it's like the
d'argent teeny endued like Argentinians
are good at soccer and I played soccer
for quite some time and then was
introduced to skating and I got hooked
on skating when I was like 11 or 12
years old and I'm talking about like
skateboarding or like it's like nah I
figure skating like inline inline
skating like aggressive inline skating
so at that time it was becoming really
popular was all over ESPN all the mobile
skate parks I would do these tours and
whatnot and I got I went to the skate
park on accident I thought was going to
a skating rink and end up at this skate
park with these huge half pipes and
bowls and all this stuff and I'll just
immediately hooked and I'm a bit of a
daredevil too so I got really good at it
really quick and even I think by the
time I was 13 or 14 I won some
competition to like tour the tour the
country with like a like an organization
that did like mobile skate parks and
there was like professional
skateboarders professional roller
bladers and professional bikers and I
was doing that at like 13 and then
skated all the way up until pretty much
high school and just kind of started
like you know venturing out just living
a little bit more normal cuz I was like
I do when I do things I'd like go
hundred percent into it it's just like
my my nature so I like figuring out how
something works I like perfecting it or
mastering the skill and then just doing
it and yeah that was about until I was
18 but I mean even like in high school I
kind of like would keep them keep my
life separate like I have my skating
friends and then I had my high school
like normal friends cuz they even what
were the high school friends like like
what kind of crowd did you fall into
like with the jocks or with like donors
or the geeks like I do I'm a chameleon
man I blend in with everybody yeah I
I've always had friends that's like a
survival it's a technique maybe you know
coming from that environment and
realizing like if I want to make this
work in the real world like I have to be
adaptable yeah yeah exactly like I was
always like a little bit more like on
the intelligent side lovely needed bands
classes so I had friends with that were
considered geeks and nerds and stuff and
like I love those people and then I
always like have the more social light
crowd where they were going to parties
and all this stuff and then the jocks
the the Goths at that time there's a lot
of gas my high school my guy I'd blend
it in with everybody you know so uh III
mean I'm sure you feed to ask hopefully
if you'd ask like a lot of my high
school friends
I was pretty well-liked throughout high
school but like many of them didn't know
like who I was at the same time they
knew who-who I portrayed you know but
then they knew the guy that you wanted
them to know almost they didn't
necessarily know yeah well few people
did a few of my close friends you know I
had like a really tight inner circle of
friends and they did and they accepted
me and they that's why I became more
comfortable being who I was with them
but then outside of that and never
really talked about like my background
or you being a vegetarian or anything
like that was there anybody else from
the community in your high school or any
other vegetarians in your high school um
nothing I remember yeah yeah all right
but the bodybuilding thing doesn't come
until much later yeah right now you and
you become this engineer yeah and do you
start hitting the weights in college or
what's what's the college experience you
got a are you in you're in Louisiana or
something like that yeah yeah so I
actually started kind of I went to the
gym for my first time ever was in my I
guess my sophomore junior year of high
school
uh-huh and I was always a small kid to I
was like a really like I was always the
shortest kid in my class and it wasn't
until like after high school that I had
like a growth spurt and I mean I might
have graduated high school at five five
a hundred and thirty pounds under and
Wow something like that
yeah no football career oh no not at all
I love football but I just knew I was
kid destroyed and ate up if I if I
played football so I went I I went to
the gym but I had no idea what I was
doing
I'll just be honest I'd go to go it was
like a social hour for me I'd see people
I'd like to think I was working out at
the time and then I end up going to
college at LSU and studying engineering
and majority of my time was spent
studying for engineering because it's a
it's a it's a difficult major to be in
but at the same time I was enjoying
college I was
you know going to football games all
that stuff I'm a huge LSU fan college
football fan and then I started hitting
the gym a little bit more cuz I was like
hey maybe I'll get a girlfriend or
something you know like I had a growth
spurt - so I was like growing and it was
nice you know
yeah and I remember my freshman year
they say you gain 15 pounds a freshman
year I really did but not in the sense
that you would like not in muscle that
came into your body a little bit a
little bit more - so I I lived like on
campus close to a Taco Bell and I
already had these things called like
points it was like a point system you
bought with the meal plan so you could
use it at different restaurants on
campus and I would go every night and
get like four I might have been five
five bean burritos cuz I didn't know how
to cook and that was like my meal before
I go to bed I eat like three bean
burritos before I go to bed and wake up
and eat - and take it with me to class
so I was eating a lot of like a Fraggle
yeah a lot of crap uh-huh essentially
and I put on like 15 pounds whenever I
was like a freshman just continue going
to the gym but still didn't really get
anywhere you know I had like a sort of
athletic body and then it wasn't until
my last year of college that I went
through a breakup and they say breakups
make body builders uh-huh that's
essentially what happened you'd be
surprised you if you do a poll ask how
many body builders started their career
because of a breakup it's a pretty high
number yeah I get a high percentage so I
broke up with my ex and started it was I
gave up alcohol at that time too and I
was like you know what I was at LSU yeah
and with only lasted for so long but I
figured if I gave up alcohol maybe I'd
get her back or I don't know what my
process was I just kind of do want to
take a step back and really figure out
who I was and I made friends with
personal trainers at a gym because I was
going to like the rec center on campus
and my ex worked there so I was like I'm
not gonna go there anymore and I went to
another gym made friends with some
personal trainers and then I really
started understanding more concepts
about training and I made like a huge
amount of progress within a year and
that was my last year of college and
then I ended up accepting a job offer in
Calif
yeah so the idea is white sand beaches
warm water
palm trees girls and bikinis riding your
bike on the beach right yeah oh yeah
that's exactly what I was thinking so
California I'm going to college like see
you later sucktown like I'm going to
California and I accepted this job offer
with an oil and gas company mind you so
I was a mechanical engineer and I got
this job offer to do I didn't even know
what the hell a job offer was for
exactly but I was like I'm going to
California and they pay well so I'm
gonna accept it and because mind you I
came from really humble beginnings as
well so money was always like a topic of
conversation and I'm not gonna be a
renunciate essentially yeah because I
saw how I saw you know growing up in a
humble household you see how much your
parents talk about it and struggle and
worry about it and they did everything
and they provided me with like a
beautiful childhood and like I'm still
amazed and how they did it but you know
I made it to my I felt like I had a duty
to them to find a great paying job so
that I would fulfill their original plan
of giving me better opportunity right so
my brother and sister had their own
paths there's you know they're they're
successful in their own ways but they
didn't follow like a straight line like
I did and I was just like I'm going this
way
and this is where the money's at so I'm
going there and I accepted this
engineering job with the intention of
working in Long Beach California I was
like well it's not LA but it's close
there's Beach there so it's got to be
like you know cool in the hiring process
they called me and they're like yeah
position in Long Beach has been you know
changed and we need you in Bakersfield
so all right you don't quite know the
difference oh not at all so I I respond
back like what's Bakersfield and they're
like that's just another job offer and I
was like all right at this point I'd
already rejected a bunch of other job
offer so I was like committed this point
it's like Google Bakersfield and I find
out it's like you know it's got terrible
air pollution it's big oil and gas town
didn't know much else about it but I was
like okay I'm going and graduated
college packed up my Jeep didn't take
anything with me and just move to
Bakersfield mm-hmm
and started working as an engineer right
and realizing that you're in sort of
California's version of the south yeah
like it's you know it's farm its
agricultural its rural yeah guys for
sure - but when you for somebody who's
never been to California when you think
of California Bakersfield is a very
different vibe oh definitely and and
nothing and nothing against Bakersfield
when I was there it's very familiar to
me but I had the dreams of like the
California
you know like skateboarding along the
boardwalk and stuff like that so I get
there and basically come back to the
south it's I think it's one of the only
it's like the most conservative county
in Kern County in California one of them
at least and start working for the oil
and gas company find out really quickly
that there's not much to do there other
than like drink in a farm I guess and
not a soul not a soul but that's how
driven I was to get out of the South and
just like kind of find a place that was
more aligned with what I believed in you
know I knew that California a little bit
more open-minded I was like hey maybe I
could thrive there find more like-minded
people I never had a problem making
friends but I did have this desire to
kind of find my tribe essentially and so
start working as an engineer it didn't
like it from the start I never liked it
basically to not bore your listeners
there to put them to sleep I was in
charge of making sure pipelines vessels
and tanks didn't blow up or leak so a
lot of compliance a lot of regulations a
very important job yeah very important a
lot of non-destructive testing
ultrasonic techniques and I was the guy
that basically walked into the
operations office the operations team
and said hey we need to shut down we
need to make a 10 million dollar repair
we're gonna have to replace two miles
worth of 16-inch pipeline which is like
their main feeder for their power plant
and everything no one wanted to hear
from you oh no it was like the most
least like department in the in the like
in the company every as soon as my team
walked in everybody like rolled their
eyes on the garlic wrap here's these
guys like we're the police essentially
that oil company while I AG in the
police department essentially yeah
essentially so you could see like my
frustrations like I feel like I'm doing
a good job but then it's not
well-received and I just got bored I got
so bored about talking about corroding
pipe and inspections and replacing
pipelines and tanks and vessels and
doing calculations all day and I just
knew it wasn't for me and I at that time
I would leave work
I've worked nine hours a day I'd leave
work go home change and just go to the
gym and that's kind of where I didn't
have anything else to do I didn't have
much friends I was like I'll just focus
on working out like I liked it that last
year of college I'll just continue to do
this because I make friends in the gym
maybe I'll meet some gym buddies I'll
get to know the town a little bit better
and that's exactly what happened so I
just made some friends in the gym
started working out with more like I
guess you could say advanced you know
bodybuilders or there was a but like the
bodybuilding community and Bakersfield's
like it's a unique place I'll just put
it that way so unique place a lot of big
dudes with big jacked-up trucks big
muscles and a lot of money too because
they work in the oil industry too so so
these guys become like your bodybuilding
mentors essentially yeah essentially so
I started hanging out a little bit of
like training understanding from your
last year in college but yeah you're
just I'm just you're just going to the
gym I'm gonna get jacked yeah right yeah
same intention same intention a big
truck yeah I have a big have a big Jeep
so I almost fit into that crowd yeah it
just wasn't the size that I wanted to be
yes not big enough yeah so so you can
see like my chameleon at work here
because I fit in with like these big
tatted up like like almost blue collar
guys but yet in like the engineering
world or the oilfield world like the
blue-collar guys don't necessarily hang
out with like the engineers too much
because there's like a you know just
like a hierarchy or whatever you want to
call it like a social system within the
community as well so I like blended in
with those guys I haven't got along with
them we go get drinks and all this stuff
and work out together and you know
naturally you got big
when you work out what guys that push
you and that's what happened and I
remember distinctly what happened was
started getting more into shape so I
started looking more into nutrition and
I was like how was nutrition affecting
my gains so that's when I started trying
to optimize my nutrition in my way of
optimizing my nutrition as a vegetarian
at that time was I'll just take a lot
more whey protein shakes because protein
equals muscle right or at least that's
what I thought right I can't eat the
chicken breast
ya know chicken breast eating eggs no
eggs yeah no eggs at that time the only
like animal-based products I was eating
was Greek yogurt and a lot of Greek
yogurt because I was like pretty high in
protein not too bad at macros and
calories a lot of whey protein shakes I
wasn't too huge on cheese except for
cheese pizza bean burritos that kind of
thing and uh and what else I think knows
about it yeah more protein the the more
protein the better essentially yeah and
if I'm not gonna eat meat I'm just gonna
be pounding these shakes exactly right
exactly and I quickly found out that my
stomach didn't digest whey protein uh we
wouldn't want to be around me if I drank
a protein shake because it was just like
I'd bloat and be gassy all day you know
I blame it on other people I'll be like
yeah that guy stinks you know but the
truth was like I wasn't meant to digest
whey protein shakes just never sat well
and then I forget exactly how the chain
of events happen but I I remember this
part I went to San Diego to visit a
friend I was driving back up the PCH
ended up stopping in Huntington Beach
because I always liked Huntington Beach
for some reason and or the vibes there I
just go along to Huntington Beach Pier
and I had like a like the beach
boardwalk that goes underneath the pier
and I was standing up there and I looked
down and there's a demonstration going
on and happened to be PETA or some kind
of animal I don't know if is PETA
exactly but it was some kind of animal
rights activist group and they had a
huge plate and on the plate they had
giant carrots giant Peas and people in
like a nude bodysuit that and they'd
look like chicken breasts you know if
you'd like took a step back and looked
from a distance and looked like a plate
of chicken peas and carrots and they had
the sign that said like how does it look
now
and you know I didn't eat meat it wasn't
it didn't affect me that much and I was
just like enjoying watching people's
reaction to that that demonstration
didn't agree oh yeah yeah they were
yelling people yelling everything was it
just wasn't a good scenario they were
handing out pamphlets and as I'm sitting
there leaning on the railing watching
this a woman comes up to me and she
hands me a pamphlet and she goes I don't
know what the hell she said but I was
just like politely handed the pamphlet
back to her and I said no thanks
I'm already vegetarian I don't eat meat
and she looked at me and I forget this
and she goes with like just like a super
condescending voice and she goes well do
you drink milk
do you eat cheese and I was like yeah
and she was like well do you know that
that's one of the most cruel industries
and it's even more cruel than the meat
industry and you're contributing to that
and like I then at that point I like
handed the pamphlet back to I was like
you know what I don't really care it's
not for me and I left and I went home
and I just thought it was a weird
scenario and as the universe would have
it again I was on Facebook and I think
my mom actually posted a video about
some kind of slaughterhouse of the dairy
industry something like that and I like
sat down and thought about it and I saw
with my own eyes this video what was
going on in like dairy farms and how the
cows were just kind of like locked in a
cage where they couldn't move their head
and they just had these mechanisms
hooked up to them and they were sucking
the juices out and I just thought to
myself I was like wow like I'm I'm
contributing to that by eating it and I
made a decision like on the spot house I
can't do this anymore
and I just decided to give up dairy
together too like as ineffective as I
thought that you know whole scenario was
it it worked because it planted a seed
in my mind and I just happen to see
another thing that reinforced it and I
just changed and I went I went
plant-based at that moment Wow
and before that you'd never flirted with
the idea of going vegan or you hadn't
developed any awareness of dairy
industry practices her name I I think I
like I knew a little bit yeah like come
on man I've never eaten meat like
mymiami alone yeah that was my argument
I was like dude I'm doing less harm
you don't kill the cow what's it like
what's the big deal
you know but yeah there was a big deal
so I ended up I ended up giving that up
and I was just like all right like now
what
like I guess I'll go vegan or I guess
I'll go plant-based and I had known what
year was this this was 25 so I'm 28 now
or 28 or actually about to be 29 29 in a
few weeks
yeah almost four years ago and I
basically started looking up plant-based
nutrition because at this time I'm still
you know very into bodybuilding and and
whatnot I knew you could build muscle I
knew there's a lot of myths out there
about not eating meat because I was like
doing it when I was building muscle
without eating meat but I really did you
know have my doubts about building
muscle without any animal product
without my my whey protein and my Greek
yogurt mm-hmm and yeah I just kind of I
was like well now I'm in it I can't go
back I'll just make this work and that's
when I started figuring out okay there's
a lot of health benefits to not eating
dairy and whey protein and all this
other stuff as so I switched over my my
way shakes with plant-based shakes I
started incorporating a lot more like
legumes and lentils into my my nutrition
program at the time and yeah just went
you know dough headfirst and what were
the resources that you were looking to
like was a YouTube videos or were you
reading books or like watching dr.
Gregers videos or like Robert Cheeke has
his vegan bodybuilding site at the time
I don't know how active he is on that
now but there were some resources
available yeah there were some at that
time I think it would have been what he
doesn't it was like 2014 the end of 2014
beginning in 2015 when that kind of
transition happened and I I looked up
vegan Fitness vegan bodybuilding that
stuff and I did come across Robert
cheeks website there's a lot of great
resources there but I'm much more like
practical guy I just like to be my own
kind of experiment and to see what works
what doesn't work you're gonna engineer
yourself that engineer that's exactly
what happened I like to figure out how
things work optimize it and maximize it
and
I just started eating more learning that
I can incorporate more carbs a little
bit less protein I read a book I wish I
could remember the name of the book it
was called like vegetarian sports
nutrition or something and I learned a
lot about that book and I just kind of
reassured that you know I can do this I
can do this and at the gym one day I was
walking into a gym and there was a guy
that was selling supplements and I knew
him he was living like a little giveaway
any type of thing and he goes hey man
you're looking pretty good you should do
a bodybuilding show I just laughed
tough like yeah right I mean did you
look how did you look then versus like
what I'm looking at right now so I was
in good shape
I was definitely good shape but I was
about 30 pounds lighter so I may be not
thirty pounds was probably out twenty
pounds lighter
so right now about 101 90 somewhere
around there at that time I was like 160
165 somewhere around there and I
literally laughed in his face like yeah
right do you like you think I'm gonna
get on stage in like a speedo and flex
in front of like a crowd of judges like
first of all would my like corporate job
think of that like if they saw pictures
floating around and me in a speedo yeah
and the Harry Krishna community Oh at
that time I had like at that time I I
had completely kind of like almost
disassociated myself with the Hari
Krishna movement because I didn't feel
like I belong to the time I had been
spending so much time in my life
suppressing it and downplaying it but I
did become disconnected like there was a
disconnection there so I stopped going
to the to the temple for a long time I
would go back to the temple when I'd go
visit my parents and whatnot but I never
really went proactively on myself and
learned more or did more reading on it
and kind of really understand the entire
thing so I wasn't worried about the
heart Krishna's and what they thought
I'm just like I can't escape like the
juxtaposition like the contrast of those
two worlds like a Lodi building world
and like the Hari Krishna community
oh yeah I'll get into that later okay
good I'll get into that later doing so
so here I am at the gym and this guy's
like can try and convince me to do his
show he's like dude it's in Bakersfield
like come on
like it's in it's in two months you got
enough time you look great I know a guy
he can help get you stage ready and I
was like no dude like that's just not
for me like I could never see myself
doing that and he he connected me with a
guy either way and I like maybe I could
learn something anyway and the guy was
like hey I should do the show he looked
great you have a good chance of winning
I was like you know what like can we
curse in here yeah yeah [ __ ] it like why
not I I well like you got going on yeah
exactly I was like I hate my job
like I might as well find something that
I'm passionate about maybe I like
working out maybe this will give me a
goal to strive for and I picked the date
and I remember I trained for eight or
nine weeks somewhere around there I
contacted this coach and he had no
experience with vegetarianism veganism
especially and he was like look I can't
help you with what to eat but maybe I
can give you some guidance on like how
much to eat so I was like is the coach
is it is it is the focus really on the
nutrition side of it or is it on the
actual training aspect of getting ready
for something like that so I thought it
was on training but you quickly realized
that it's all about nutrition hmm you
know it's if you have a good foundation
and you focus strictly on nutrition you
don't even have to go to the gym and you
can because if you can get lean enough
yeah like it ever comes the fitness
because you looked more jacked than you
actually are exactly like we all have
muscle under here it's just about trying
to expose it right so if you just eat
correctly you can expose that muscle a
lot greater by reducing it on a body fat
you have on your on your body so he
helped me with how much to eat and I was
just kind of left in the lab you know
mad scientist I don't like picking
different foods and experimenting and
trying to see which foods work best that
to yield the best results so like as you
could imagine I'm a data-driven person
so I would track everything and track my
workouts I tracked how much I ate how
many calories I'm the micronutrients
micronutrients everything was in the
nutritional program that I was following
and I'm like spreadsheets oh yeah I'm a
spreadsheet guru man yeah we're getting
your your workout routines from this
commutes at the gym a combination the
combination so he gave me a workout
routine and I followed it and then I did
my own stuff like
I always had my own routines and I would
do because I knew what like worked best
for me and you know eight weeks later go
by and you know now we're here at the
show day and I'm like terrified I'm like
what am i doing like I didn't get up
there and like a what do you call it a
speedo I didn't get up there on a speedo
I did a different division called men's
physique and they wear the board shorts
they waited like the beach even know
that they were different oh yeah there's
a lot of different these lot you don't
know about bodybuilder man so this is a
different subculture
this is not IFBB no no so this was the
organization called imba which is
international natural bodybuilding
association and hold on a second because
I like this is like a subculture I know
nothing about so do you like shave your
body and do the fake tan thing and put
the oil all over you and like and are
you starving yourself for like a week to
get as lean as Pike is it like a
wrestler protocol where you're trying to
literally lose as much not just fat but
water content like what does that look
like yeah so it's it's kind of similar
to a wrestling protocol or like an MMA
protocol but you want to be as efficient
as possible so you want to reduce as
much body fat you want to reduce as much
water retention as possible in the final
week well actually the leaks the weeks
leading up to it you want to reduce as
much body fat the final week you're more
focused on reducing the amount of water
retention you have so you can appear as
lean and crisp as possible right and
what are the techniques for doing that
similar to similar to wrestling where
you do water loading can we do a lot of
cardio where like that suit that makes
you sweat some people do Red Mill some
people do I'm not a big sweater so I
don't really sweat that much water out
of me and it's not a really good
approach because you just reintroduce
water and you you store it again so the
way it works is that like the week
leading up to the show is called peak
week and there's different strategies
for it at that time what I was doing was
water loading at the beginning of the
week so I'd drink like start off at 1
gallon then I'd go to 2 gallons a day
then I go to 3 gallons a day and then
towards the end of the week I would I
would basically sorry I'll go back out
drink out water loaded
beginning of the week and I would reduce
as much as possible the amount of carbs
I was eating because the theory is that
carbs attract water you want to deplete
all of your glycogen stores so all of
this extra fluff and water that you have
in your system you want to burn as many
calories and deplete yourself as much as
possible so you look really like a
raisin like shriveled and flat and you
can't get a pump in the gym is just
miserable you're like you have carb head
the carb fog so they call you can't
think straight you get hangry yeah and
it's so ironic because you feel terrible
right but then your skin's like
paper-thin
exactly exactly as I tell me about this
all the time like it's the guys on stage
they look the best but they feel the
worst yeah well you hear that all the
time also you you know these guys will
say and I'm sure you would mimic this
that you can only maintain you you
whatever that you know you get that
photograph on stage and then literally
like six hours later you you know when
you when you finish and then you eat or
you drink water then it goes away yes
you can only maintain it for like the
just tiniest finite amount of time
exactly a beautifully put so like I said
my grandpa was a airline pilot so I like
to use this analogy it's like you're
landing a plane so you see your target
you see your runway and you choose that
X amount of weeks in advance so you want
to slowly lower there descend to that
target so if you go you know 12 weeks
out from a show just cut out all your
food do as much cardio as possible
you're gonna kill yourself you're gonna
spin you're gonna burn out you know so
it's about kind of timing everything to
the exact hour of stepping on stage so
you're trying to land this plane the
final week would be the landing gears
coming out and then touchdown would be
stepping on stage so the final basically
24 hours before the show at that time
what I was doing I still kind of do it
now you so your water loading all week
then towards the end of the week you
taper off and then you completely stop
drinking water the night before and what
happens is that the theory is and I
talked with some doctor about the kind
of more of the metabolic process that
goes on
behind the theory and he confirms some
of it that you know the more water you
drink your body will release a hormone
to dispel more water to kind of keep
things going and if you do water loading
and then you cut it off then that
hormone will still be there so there's
like a lag period and you'll just kind
of pee out more water than you should so
it's like you're draining yourself
completely of water and then the body
thinks well water's coming yeah Ben
comment yeah so the gear is still going
right so the wheel still turning and
then you reintroduce carbs the day
before and the day of the show so you
gotta haul carb loading so guys will
pound thousand grams of carbs Friday a
thousand grams of carbs before they step
on stage and what happens is it it
basically the theory is that glycogen
attracts water so it'll now that you're
introducing glycogen to your muscles
it's sucking all the water to your
muscles so it's giving you this really
good pump and this fullness right so
that's crazy yeah I mean it's a really
crazy concept to put your body through
this amount of torture to to just
basically appear a certain way for a
short period of time you you train 10
weeks for 10 seconds on stage like
that's how crazy bodybuilding is and
yeah but but in fairness you know Usain
Bolt trains years for however long it
takes him to run Traylor meters it's not
that different yeah that's a very good
point it's just a funny concept to me
still to this day it's a funny it is
comical when you guys think about it
yeah and then on top of that on top of
that you put yourself through so much
effort and you you end up paying to do
these contests then you pay somebody who
you've never met to judge you on how you
look and there's a certain amount of
self-worth that you get whenever people
tell you that hey you don't look as good
as that guy I'll just tell you right now
so we're gonna place you at the end of
the line a weird thing yeah and there's
a weird you know let's let's face it
there's a bizarre like strain of
narcissism oh definitely no and it is a
sport and I respect that and I'm super
interested in hearing what you have to
say about the world but it's it's
distinct from other sports in a very
unique way
so you have to be a little extreme to be
a bodybuilder like in some sense you
have to be extreme as a person's
personality there has to be something
there in order for you to go through
that same is all like elite level
athletes I feel like we have this thing
about us then what is that thing like is
there is there a common like personality
or emotional archetype that you see that
drives people into this world I think a
lot of it is the dream I think a lot of
is that dream and then allure of being
the best bodybuilder in the world having
this like insanely attractive physique
and something happens to that whole
process to where that might be the goal
initially but then a lot of people
really do fall in love with it and it
becomes their meditation their therapy
to go to the gym and just work on
yourself so I had respect to all body
builders in all types and forms but I
feel like we all share that commonality
amongst us all right so let's go back to
this first competition so you're
learning all of this as you go right
first competition you train for eight or
nine weeks or whatever it is you get up
on the board with the board shorts on
yeah what happens yeah so we go through
the whole process - so the tanning is
first time I'm gonna spray tan my life
was just like not the last yeah
definitely not the last
unfortunately so I get spray tan I go on
stage and I do my my posing routine and
I entered I think two divisions at that
time it was like the novice and then the
open class because I was like hey maybe
I might win the novice maybe I'll get
destroyed in the open so I entered two
physique or two categories ended up
going on stage twice so give me a little
bit more stage time more experience and
I did my posing routine I had like my my
girlfriend at the time a couple friends
in the front row so it was like a
hometown show for me so they were all
cheering me on so I got like a lot more
confident when I was on stage and you
know you got you just skipped over the
fact that you got a girlfriend in
Bakersfield
I did okay yeah yeah and so as a show
would have it I ended up winning the
novice division and then won the overall
for the novice division and then I in
the open division I won
my class in the open and then won the
overall for the open so I basically
swept the entire show in my divisions
and I walked home that day with like six
trophies like it was weird I had like
six trophies a plaque and this gigantic
bodybuilder trophy that was like no I
think he was like this like just both
arms raised and I was like this is so
cool like this is all the hard work that
I've been working for insist big gold
plastic trophy you know and literally
brand new to the sport first competition
ever yeah that's crazy so so a funny
thing happened after that
obviously I was really happy but the
question that I avoided my entire life
was now the most common question that I
was getting and that is what do you eat
so I was forced to tell them that you
know I did it all vegan I did it all
plant-based so going into that nobody
knew that was just your thing I didn't
know who you were any no no I mean
amongst the gym members made some of
people may have known who I was but
Baker feels a pretty small town um word
gets around really quick there and you
know they were really shocked I had to
two impressions whenever I tell people
that I did it without eating this
standard typical proto they're the the
prototypical bodybuilding diet which is
like chicken and rice egg whites in the
morning wash it down with a protein
shake then you drink you're eating your
salmon and asparagus so all of these
things are very heavily animal-based and
they're consuming a large amount of it
too so the fact that somebody just won a
bodybuilding competition without eating
any of that is a little bit like
concerning or just like disbelieving to
people so on top of that it's worth
noting that you know a common thing that
you also hear with people that are with
vegan athletes or vegetarian athletes
for that matter is yeah that's fine
but he only stopped eating meat like a
year ago or two years ago or five years
ago he made all his gains he got big
when he was playing football in college
when he was eating meat all the time
you've never had meat in your whole life
yeah but yeah a vegan thing didn't come
in until the lead up to this competition
so you mean for this specific event
mm-hmm totally vegan for the first time
yeah
so basically ten weeks before that I
went vegan
and I basically made it really
challenging for myself was like I'm
gonna train for my first bodybuilding
show I'm gonna train as a vegan I have
no idea what to do for both but I'm
gonna figure it out and so I started
telling people I was like look I you're
not gonna like it but I did it all vegan
I did eating like at that time I was
like I was relying on like um
alternative meats so I'd have like
veggie chicken and what else was I
having just like a lot of lentils like
high carb foods which was kind of going
against the grain too and people were
just kind of like immediately turned off
and they were like yeah that's cool
whatever and then they just like go
about their day but then I found out
that I shared it on social media like I
never once made like an announcement and
like hey I'm going vegan like a lot of
people do now I just kind of did it
behind the scenes and then I just kind
of came on the scene as like a vegan and
I shared like pictures and I was like
you know I just won this bodybuilding
competition and people say you can't
build muscle without me and I did it you
know so I get a lot of like positive
feedback from that from people and a lot
of people asking me questions online not
necessarily in real life some people are
interested in real life but online I
figured I could probably reach some
people that were like me and didn't
believe it was possible so maybe I can
inspire somebody and I started sharing
my journey a little bit more mm-hmm and
that's kind of where this whole thing
began right and we're gonna get into
that but just sort of back in this
lead-up to this competition I'm
interested in your experience training
for the first time vegan like when you
made that switch okay I'm not doing the
dairy anymore what was the experience in
the gym like did you you know where your
gains truncated by that did it help your
training did it hinder it like how did
you kind of navigate figuring out how to
make it work so the first thing I
noticed whenever I cut out the dairy
products was how much better I felt like
from a digestion point of view I didn't
experience the the bloat the gas the
discomfort that I felt quite often
whenever I would eat dairy products and
I just figured that I was
lactose-intolerant never got tested for
it I just figured I wasn't really
digesting it that well so that was the
reason behind it so as soon as I cut
that out I realized that I had this like
new sense of clarity a new sense of
energy in the gym and I wasn't like I
wasn't getting a sore anymore so what
happened was is that I could train more
frequently because I wasn't as sore the
next day I was like well I guess I'm
gonna train again like my I feel good
like I'm just gonna do it and I
immediately noticed that I could train
more and that therefore you train more
frequently you see better results
quicker so it was immediate the the
feeling and I was already eating really
clean mind you so it was just that next
level of cleaning up the diet even more
yeah that's what you hear all the time
it's not that going plant-based
inherently makes you a better athlete
but my experience and it sounds like
your experience and the experience that
you hear from so many people who have
made this switch is that it expedites
the recovery process you know the fact
that you weren't sore means the body is
repairing itself more expeditiously than
what you were accustomed to so in turn
you can push yourself a little bit
harder you can train a little bit more
frequently you can go a little bit
longer you're less likely to get injured
or have to take a rest day or to get
sick because you over trained and when
you protract that over the course of a
season or a number of months or even
years you're gonna have serious
performance gains as a result mm-hmm so
yeah basically when you train for a
bodybuilding show you experience all
those things like cumulative ly right so
I noticed the difference and I feel like
touching on what you talked about
earlier is that people they don't know
they feel a certain way because it's
just their normal right so I never knew
that there was another approach that I
could feel sore less which couldn't
allow me to train more because I just
knew that I worked out I would get sore
it would take me X amount of days to
recover I just think that's how it was
and now this vegetarian mind you so I
always feel like everybody has their own
sense of like homeostasis and there
normality that they kind of always
linger around right so imagine all the
people that are out there listening and
they are consuming this diet that
they've been eating their entire life
and it's just normal it's normal to feel
like lethargic after eating a heavy meal
it's normal to feel this way the entire
day to have to take a nap or that you
get headaches every day or that you know
you just have this irritable bowel
syndrome or whatever the case is it's
just normal and then you cut something
out and there's like a new sense of
normal and you're like whoa I feel great
like this is what it's like this is what
it's like to feel this way I never knew
there was possible so essentially that's
kind of the transition that most people
experience when they go plant-based
because it's like they're they're
experiencing this new energy this new
sense of thriving and the performance
comes after like you know you have
better mental clarity you can think
better you're happier you're more likely
to be more productive you know go longer
in the gym yeah it's all good that yeah
so after that first competition are you
thinking like hey maybe I have a career
here like the universe was you know loud
and clear like hey man you're pretty
good at this
no so what comes next no I would never
say that I thought I had a career in it
at that point I thought you know what I
want a local show there wasn't that many
people what did I really win you know
like there was no it wasn't like a
serious amount of competition there so
that's when I looked at other
competitions like coming up and I found
one in Fresno and I was like okay this
is a bigger show bigger city a lot like
more established competition so I was
like I'm gonna go for that one mm-hmm
the difference was that it was
non-tested so I knew going into it that
I'd be going against guys that were
probably taking stuff or so it's a
different it wasn't it's not this isn't
the boardshorts organization this is
like a different no still be still
boardshorts but different Federation
uh-huh so it's like just different
organizers different set of contest
rules regulations and
testing just means they're not drug
testing yeah so you know these guys are
gonna be jacked up on whatever yeah I
mean that's not to say everybody but I
knew that that was a very strong
possibility that that I'd be going up
against guys that were probably at a big
advantage compared to me
and I entered that show I don't know how
many weeks later it was but I entered
that one and ended up winning the
overall there and at that point right
then I was like okay there is no
limitation to this there's I'm not
restricted by this diet I can compete
against guys doesn't matter what their
diet or their lifestyle is I can compete
and that's what it really are still
brand new yeah yeah so I have so much
potential out there waiting for you yeah
I think when you win at anything it
makes you a little bit more inspired of
course to work harder and see what else
you could do and that's that's kind of
where I was at when I won the second
competition and how does it work does
somebody come up to you after the
competition and go hey like let me take
you to the next level or you should do
this now or let me guide you or you know
how what are the mechanics of how it
unfolds know so they have like different
it's like a qualification series so if
you competed it like a national level
show sorry a national qualifier you have
to place in a certain rank to be able to
compete at the next level which is all
the winners so that's the national show
and then the national show if you win a
certain rank normally its first or
second in your class then you get
awarded a pro card so that's kind of
like the progression there it's almost
like going from like the high school to
college to the pros and after I won that
second show I was like man I I'm
qualified there's a national show next
year I think I can I think I can compete
uh-huh so that was about my new bill
right so then what happens there so I
think like maybe a year and a half later
I did a couple other shows and won some
I got second and some and I was still
qualified for the national show and then
that's when I was like okay if like
what's my goal here I was like if I can
prove because I it goes in stages right
first people say you can't build muscle
without me mm-hmm
then people say you can't win a
bodybuilding show without me I did both
of those
people say well you can't compete
against the pros and then it is like
that bar keeps getting set a little bit
further like okay well this floral
because the cognitive dissonance is so
is so deep that no matter how many times
you continue to defy it that the
goalposts just keep moving they've got a
point to some other reason that that
affirms their worldview exactly so I'm
like to this point I was so kind of like
watch me just watch me right so that was
the drive that was not right I was
coming from yeah in a sense and you
start sharing this stuff on social media
so now this is becoming like a public
thing yeah so then I started like waving
this flag and I was like hey I'm doing
it this way like there's a different
approach that I didn't know existed like
I found that the secret sauce so those
who were interested I want to learn more
about it you know come follow because
I'll be posting about it a lot more and
following my journey and that's where
the whole social media aspect started a
kind of snowballing and getting a little
bit more well-known within that
community and you know it's like I said
a year and a half later Here I am going
into my first national show and it's the
biggest show of them all in Las Vegas
and I don't know how many guys there are
per class but essentially each there's
like six or seven high classes each one
of the height classes is larger than
most of the local cumulative amount of
people mm-hmm so there's more people in
a high class and there isn't a total
competition right and a local level so
and you're in the speedo now no no still
in the bore short really yes same same
division just different Federation and
you're supposed to see the quads they
don't they don't judge on this one so
they're different there's different
levels of bodybuilding goes like super
heavyweight then like heavyweight and
then like different weight classes and
they go like classic physique which is
like kind of like there's height and
weight limitations then they go men's
physique which is one that I'm in and
it's more like more the cover model
aesthetic kind of not so massive guys
not like mr. Olympia no there is a do
can't compete to be mr. Olympia but in
that division but not like guys like
Phil Heath that are just just huge like
pounds on stage dry and so there I am
going to my first contest and I ended up
winning my class so that meant I was
award I was going to be awarded my pro
card and I walked off stage at that
point and I got like super just like
emotional like I had reached my goal I
became a professional athlete and it was
it was just like overwhelming so I
stepped off stage and I was just like
wow I did it like I really did it and I
was just thinking in my head I was like
this is gonna do so much good for
everything I represent because now
people can point to somebody and say hey
you can be a pro because that guy did it
you know you can compete against elite
level bodybuilders because that guy did
it and that was kind of my like one of
my reasons for doing it I love
bodybuilding and everything else but it
becomes much easier to immerse yourself
in work and sacrifice whenever you're
doing it for something beyond yourself
okay because bodybuilding is a very very
vain sport you have to be have to be
selfish you have to be vain because the
only way you can get to that level is by
only focusing on one thing you know and
that's building up your physique so the
fact that I was doing it or I had this
kind of like team behind me and I was
representing them so I felt like I
couldn't let them down now so I had to
work hard I had to stick to everything
and now that I went pro I was like we
made it guy was just me making it was
everybody making it and that's kind of
where I like I decided like yeah now I'm
really gonna be vocal about it because
now you can't tell me [ __ ] because now
I'm a pro so what's your Excuse now like
what more do I have to prove and then
now the the argument now the argument is
like yeah but you can't make it to
Olympia like all right watch me just
watch me so give me some time that's
what's next that's what's next and how
big is that leap from what you've
accomplished to Olympia not much not
much so they changed up the the
qualification for Olympia now but it was
previously if you won an overall at an
Olympia qualifier which is normally like
a big pro show then you automatically
get to go to Olympia like you won first
and if you on that no I haven't done
that yet but if you get second third or
fourth
fifth you get a series of points and at
the end of the year the guys with the
most points get invited so now since
there's so many guys that are competing
again they went to a point system so you
have to compete year-round now and place
in the top five consistently to get the
most points by the end of the year and
they invite the top thirty guys I
stopped forty guys to to Olympia I see
so you're now training for various
events and trying to accumulate those
points yeah yeah essentially so how how
far or close are you to that so this
year wasn't what I wanted to be there
was a couple things happened between
2017 and 2018 so I moved from
Bakersfield to Long Beach in California
basically I went through this self
awakening I was like I can't live here
anymore
like it's I'm capping out I'm like
limiting I was in a bad relationship and
I need to get out so I I went on a trip
to Bali and just had this like kind of
like self aligning moment where I was
like what am i doing like I only live
once why am I wasting my time slaving
away for something that I'm just not
bringing me any happiness or joy so I
went back home went to my boss's office
that first thing I was like look you
need to find another place for me in
this company or I need some time off to
go interview for other companies
elsewhere because I just can't do it
anymore he was like don't quit there's a
spot for you in Long Beach so as I'm
transferring to Long Beach thought that
would solve my problems as far as being
unhappy with a job because it was a new
location it wasn't close to LA all my
friends a lot more to do I worked there
for five months and I was more miserable
than ever because now I was garnering a
lot more attention on social media and
seeing like firsthand the impact that I
was making to the people that I was
trying to reach and I remember I went to
an event in London and I gave a speech
in front of I don't know how many people
500 people something like that and
afterwards a guy came up to me and said
that I helped save his mom's life and I
was like how's that and he goes well you
were the reason that I went vegan and my
mom was a type-2 diabetic she couldn't
get out of the bed and
she saw how I was surviving and thriving
on a vegan diet so she was willing to
try it and since she went plant-based
she's able to move around she like cured
a lot of her her illnesses and I
completely think that you helped save
her life and it like brought me to tears
not just like still gives me like going
now and I was like what am i doing like
why am I wasting 910 hours a day for
something that I hate and technically
you're a professional athlete yeah and
like I didn't tell anybody at work like
in Bakersfield people knew at in Long
Beach I didn't tell anybody because I
didn't want them to know and I was like
so they kind of like going to this is a
half a saw like go to events and like
London and give speeches right without
evolution well no that one was London
veg fest that was London veg fest so
like Here I am going to London travel
different countries giving speeches
about something I'm so passionate about
and then coming home talking about
happiness and talking about living your
dream and I come home and living a
nightmare
so I kid I went to the office that
Monday there was a 6:30 meeting and we
start talking on the same [ __ ] corroding
pipe compliance different projects and I
I've felt this like I've never felt this
before like such a state of
claustrophobia that everything was like
closing in around me and I had to like
get up and leave the room and I knew
that as soon as yeah panic attack yeah I
started like hyperventilating and as
soon as the meeting was done didn't go
back in the meeting as soon as the
meeting was over I went to my boss's
office close the door and I was like I'm
putting in my resignation like this is
my last two weeks or week or something
and he was like whoa like where's this
coming from so so he was like you know
what are you gonna do and I'll never
forget this conversation like he's a
pretty level-headed guy I try to explain
to him that I have like you know this
passion for spreading awareness about
veganism I'm a bodybuilder he's like
yeah I figured you were like something
and I explained it to him and he goes he
goes so you're quitting to become a
vegan
and I'd go perfect I go I'm already like
in a sense yes a professional vegan a
professional vegan yeah to talk about
vegan professionally and yeah I didn't
expect him to understand and he was like
well you know congrats to you you know
he was really receptive of it and I'd
only been working there a couple months
and he was like you got bigger balls
than I do cuz you know I got like a
family to feed and all this stuff so I
can't make that jump but props to you
for following your heart and following a
dream then like it's a good man yeah you
off with well wishes oh yeah we haven't
we had a great relationship and great
guy and everything and I really
appreciate that conversation too but
then it's like alright well like now how
am I gonna make this work yeah yeah
exactly so so I mean I'm going back to
the London thing I felt like I was doing
a disservice to the community and to so
many other things by not fully investing
myself into like my purpose that I felt
like I had to and that was the main
reason why I quit my job I you know I
was like you know what I'll figure it
out yeah I'm giving up like a really
well-paying job like six figures at 23
you know so I'll make it work because
money's not everything you know I have a
ton of money in the bank account or I
did whenever I was like working there
sounds like I have a lot of money in a
bank account what happiness is brung me
nothing so but when I'm truly happy
money doesn't matter because it's like
I'm having a sense of fulfillment and
I'm helping people and that's what I
really it's your version of renunciation
in the modern world yeah you know like
that that that's what ever compelled
your mom it's almost like that same
trigger came up for you as I came full
circle yeah is what happened I thought
that all these things would bring me
happiness you know having a title having
a well-paying job having a condo on the
beach you know the material things I
thought it would bring me happiness but
you know the more you work for it the
more you become a slave to it and after
I kind of renounced it and just kind of
sat back and I was like immediately had
like regret I was like what the hell did
I just do right like I just [ __ ] this
up
that's gonna happen now yeah
and well that and there's that like
projection that perhaps some people have
that they're placing on you like oh well
he's a pro like he's getting paid in
like like their sponsors and there's all
this there's the reality versus the
imagined reality that perhaps your
social media following might have
projected upon you yeah people have this
idea that when you cam a professional
bodybuilder the opportunity just come
reining in and you get paychecks left
and right like you don't get paid like
you pay you pay them you pay them like
it they put it this way if you win a
bodybuilding show in my division you
might get two to three thousand dollars
to win first place how much does it cost
you to go to Denver pay for a hotel room
pay for a flight pay for all the meals
like you break even like even though you
might win a small purse you break even
so people thinking that they're gonna
become super rich from being a pro
bodybuilder it's like you're going in it
for the wrong reasons I'll tell you
right now you got to find something else
to go in it for like maybe
self-satisfaction or whatever but yeah I
think I I did have some sponsors at that
point and that was kind of what was like
sustaining me economically and I just
knew that whatever I did I was gonna do
it fully 100% and now I wasn't jumping
like playing this teeter-totter game
where I was like half in half out and I
was just gonna see where where it would
take me and that's kind of where I'm at
now mm-hmm yeah so now you got you
started the Generation V podcast and you
do like online coaching programs right
is that like the main source of revenue
for you at the moment or how are you how
are you making it work so yeah I mean
you know you're like you're in social
media as well there's many different
ways to make money as a social-media
influencer you can do it by endorsement
deals you can do it by sponsorships you
can do it by one-off posts you can do it
there's a million different ways I had
some money in the bank and I knew I
wanted to start something and something
that was my own be my own boss because I
never really sat well with having a boss
telling me something to do so I decided
that you know I can train people because
I'm a you know I know the process and
the system on how to make it work
because I'm like
other people before but I never had time
to train somebody when I was working as
an engineer so now I'm at this
crossroads and I'm like okay do I want
to become a personal trainer like no
because like you can train maybe nine
ten people a day and then you're capped
out and I was like it doesn't make much
sense so I figured that I wanted like my
goal has always been big like I want to
reach a lot of people and have the
biggest impact possible so as a universe
would have it I got connected with
another guy and he's like a software
engineer and we put together a system to
where we could scale coaching and help a
lot of people at once become vegan or
try you know go plant-based and research
fitness goals and we were trying to come
up with a name for it we didn't like any
of the names and we have all these names
on a paper piece of paper and he's like
into web design and SEO search engine
and everything so he's like what about
what about this one I was like yeah
right we'll never get that and it was
called vegan Fitness comm and I was like
that'd be beautiful but there's got to
be 30 40 K at least and turns out he did
a little search and shows who owns it
and it was one of our good friends oh
really that on that on the domain name I
wasn't doing it wasn't sitting on it
yeah just redirecting it to something
else and he we told him we wanted to do
he's also very philanthropic and all
about the movement progressing the
movement had big plans for it and just
gave it to us at a very homey discount
and that's amazing and we ended up with
vegan Fitness comm and so now we're
doing online coaching where we have
really big plans for it as well we have
we want it to be basically
nutritionfacts.org meets
bodybuilding.com and we want to reach
the younger demographic
because that's the generation that's
gonna make the biggest impact moving
forward and if we can convince young
guys especially that being vegan is cool
you know you can build muscle you can
get the girls you can look a certain way
you can perform as an athlete even
better then we then we've really tapped
into the the change right so it's about
making vegan cool and approachable and
doctors do such a good job of breaking
down the science
the evidence behind it but let's face it
a 20 year old doesn't give a [ __ ] about
heart disease thank you dude I'm 20 I'm
invincible
I could jump off this building and punch
you in the face and nothing's gonna
happen to me right so we want to appeal
to that generation and say hey you know
yeah you get all these extra long-term
benefits but right now you can be a
better athlete you can look better
perform better and yeah we're just we're
trying to tap into that demographic and
make it cool
that's the keys to the kingdom and what
is your sense of like where we're at
right now in terms of influencing that
demographic reading close we're getting
close I think with enough particularly
athletes I feel like they have a lot
more influence than other people doesn't
matter if a doctor saying it to you yeah
you know you eat this way you become
healthier but if Kobe Bryant walks up to
he's like you know you're a basketball
player you love him you want to be the
next Kobe Bryant he's like hey you know
if you do this you could you could be me
if that dude is gonna change that day
right so we kind of have that mentality
that approach to convincing the younger
generation to give it a try not not to
go fully plant-based just keep it a try
you know I'll convince you to try it the
diet will convince you to stick with it
give it two weeks give it three weeks
you know learn from the experts learn
the reasons how to do it or learn the
process how to do it and then the rest
will just work itself out well like I
said at the outset I mean you're the
perfect you're the perfect person to be
doing this you know you have the
physique you have the understanding you
have the accolades you're handsome dude
you're jacked you know you're photogenic
like you've got you have all the
qualities to be able to penetrate that
sector of the population and really
shift culture in a huge way like I think
it's exciting it's it's really exciting
and that's kind of where it's a big
responsibility to help it's gotta be
that link or that bridge between
mainstream and subculture but I'm
willing to give it a try I'm gonna take
it on and you know it's I think you
mentioned Muscle & Fitness yeah how did
that how did that cover come together
for you man I don't even know I don't
even know like I had shot for muscle and
fitness before after
Pro and I was like [ __ ] yeah like I'm
gonna be a muscle and fitness like it
was right after I went pro like the week
after and I did this like eight hour
shoot and with one of the best Fitness
photographers in the game and it was
like a agency that contacted me to do
the shoot they're like yeah we like your
look would you be interested in saying
hell yeah we'll be so I did the shoot
like three months four months later the
issue comes out and I'm like dude I'm
gonna be in it like there's gonna be
pictures of me and muscle and fitness
and you know maybe they'll talk about me
being vegan or something I open up the
article not even my name was mentioned
like they even gave me credit for the
for my name and I was like yeah yeah
they just used you first I was just like
a stock photo like it was like a whole
program like it was like it was like a
seven page spread so I was like all over
this this edition and not even like one
mention of my name at lea gave that they
gave the hairdresser credit they didn't
give me credit and I was like happy but
like I had people message me maybe
LaHaye they don't mention your name or
anything and I was like what's me you
know you can see me it's me and so that
happened 2016 and then ironically
somebody contacted me from Muscle &
Fitness again and we're like hey we know
you did a shoot with this guy John 16
wondering if you'd be interested in
doing another shoot like as a model for
a program that was you know they
designed and I was like yeah of course
I'd love to I was like talking with the
editor and I was like you know I would
also like to talk about this thing that
I have going on here and you know I'm
like one of the only I'm the only male
IFBB professional bodybuilder in my
division and I'm kind of helping carry
the torch to show people what's possible
without eating meat I'd love to talk
about that and he was like uh yeah let
me let me see what my like
editor-in-chief says turns out the
editor-in-chief or somebody up there was
vegan and they're like run it really a
muscle in fitness yeah they were like
run it so the guy calls me and we do
like a pretty long interview over the
phone didn't think anything of it was
gonna be like a little sub article or
something and then the day comes with a
photo shoot and again we shoot for like
nine ten hours he's
it's grueling to do one of those
photoshoots I don't how many you've done
but oh man it's not I've done I've done
let me count zero body well I think this
it's exhaust but here's one thing I will
I will tell a funny story like I have I
have shot with photographers that have
shot bodybuilders like that have shot
for muscle and fitness and I said so so
tell me how that works you know there
and they go through the whole thing like
here you gotta like you know flex your
stomach and like exhale all your air and
like you know there's a whole thing to
like make you look super epic right yeah
yeah I mean we spent we spent an hour at
least
setting up lighting right he's like
stand there shadows yes just fan there I
think it's like you know hold the weight
he's like stop when you get down and
really show me some effort cool takes
like 10 photos you do it again he looks
at the he looks at the screen he's like
not got to do it again your hairs your
hairs off so you do it again do it again
do it again do it again next thing you
know 50 pounds feels like 300 pounds and
you're like and on top that you have to
keep like a you know somewhat of a
decent face and contract muscles and be
very conscious of everything ice make
sure that every muscle you have is
flexing yeah yeah so do that for eight
hours for ten different exercises of 15
different exercises and at the shoot he
was like oh we're gonna do a cover try
and I was like what's that and he's like
we're gonna try and shoot like maybe
they'll take it for a cover I was like
yeah okay well we'll go ahead and do it
so we shot for the cover and that was
that that was that it was like a week
before I did the armor classic in March
and I was really happy with the photo
shoot because I was seen the pictures
and I was like it's awesome it looks
great and that was last thing I heard
and he was like yeah the additional
probably come out like you know a couple
of months later and you know as luck
would have it I was just sitting on the
couch one morning and a friend of my
another pro bodybuilder sends me a DM
and it's a it's the cover of his muscle
and Fitness's it's me on the cover and
I'm like where did you get this and he's
like dude I just got an email from them
talking about how Muscle & Fitness is
merging with another magazine company
and
you were on the cover and I was like
again that sense of like holy crap like
what just happened
I got no notification whatsoever they
didn't tell me I even told you never
even toe and after that I was just like
completely awestruck and didn't believe
it was real like it's still surreal to
me too and and on the front page it says
something about Annie my Delgado vegan
bodybuilding tips or something like that
so even mentioned veganism on the cover
of muscle and fit yeah that's a paradigm
shift that's like a cultural moment it's
a huge man and like I don't know I
didn't do the research and go back to
all their covers and everything I don't
know if there's been a vegan athlete on
it before but just for them to even
mention the fact that you know the word
vegan on the cover is a huge win for the
entire vegan movement and then I get if
I finally get my hands on a copy I open
it up it's a ten-page spread first page
says meatless muscle and it's got like a
cow with like an X through it it talks
about my whole story and how I've never
eaten meat and how you don't need me to
build muscle and I'm a pro bodybuilder
and just goes through my whole story
what we just talked about and it was
just such a yeah such a like a fork in
the road like a shift like a man if
Muslim Fitness is catching on us is huge
did it change things for you or what was
the reaction to that article so the
reaction is really positive online I
asked all my my followers to like go buy
a copy first because I understand how
capitalism works you know if that copy
sells more than the rest of the copies
chances are they'll feature another
vegan on the cover in the future or if
we request more information on vegan
athletes then they'll feature them
because there's a demand for it so I
convinced all my followers say go buy a
copy take a picture with it tag me tag
Muscle & Fitness let them know that we
as a movement support each other and we
want it and it was it was overwhelming
how many photos dm's everything I got
from that and since then they translated
it into different languages as well so
it's been it like I think right now it's
in Germany as the cover it's in France
it's in Turkey it's in Japan
all these different countries and it's
the same article just translated so like
the whole world got exposure to the
possibilities of a vegan diet that's
amazing man super cool well let's uh
let's bust a few myths here like I'm
interested in how your nutrition has
evolved and how it stands in contrast to
kind of conventional wisdom about what a
bodybuilder should eat right and kind of
where you started and how its morphed
over time into whatever it is now yes so
the nutrition program that I originally
started on was really reliant on kind of
processed alternative needs
yeah alternative meats and over the last
like year maybe a year and a half I kind
of started you know eliminating those
and introducing more Whole Foods more
less processed high protein foods like
tofu and tempeh edamame some I don't I
don't do seitan just because I I don't
know it gives me heartburn
and then plant-based protein shakes and
a lot of beans a lot of less specific
type that you like or for what for the
protein powders yeah I'm sponsored by a
brand right now and I like it and yeah
there's many out there like I don't want
this to be a plug but like there's just
many other plant-based alternatives out
there for I mean that you can substitute
easily and has just as much protein
probably got a little bit better
digestibility from like a comfort level
so a lot of people deal with that same
discomfort that I had when they they
drank whey protein shakes and a lot of
people don't experience that when they
go to a plant-based shake right and what
is the relationship to protein in
general and how is that kind of evolved
for you like what is what's the
conventional wisdom where did you start
with it where are you at with it now
like really specifically because this is
I mean it's like number one it's the
protein question right like we ought to
answer this question yeah no I'd be glad
to so originally I was one of those
people thinking that you know you had to
consume more protein and that would
equate to more muscle more gains then I
realized that
you know everything I read from like a
clinical study point of view not
necessarily bodybuilding.com
nothing against them they have a lot of
great information I'll read from like a
lot of other influencers or bodybuilders
they go with like the more as better
approach so you know 2 grams 2 to 3
grams sometimes every pound of every
pound of weight so if I was 180 pounds I
would need 360 grams of protein you know
at least so that's a lot for a vegan
that's a that's a lot a lot because you
know to get that much protein through
plants you got to eat a lot of volume so
I started looking at it and just like it
didn't make sense to me I was like
everything I read said like there was
like an optimal point and anything above
that didn't really work to your benefit
you know you might have extra calories
but your body kind of just like urinates
the extra nitrogen and you can't really
use it like there's a limiting factor
there so I go by lean body mass so just
because somebody's 200 pounds doesn't
need you don't need to consider them 200
pounds of muscle you know we have body
fat so you don't need to feed the body
fat you can feed the muscle so I always
go by I calculate my lean body mass
which is your total mass - your body fat
percentage so if I weighed 200 pounds
and I was 10 percent body fat then I
would my lean body mass would be 180 I'm
your lady granddaughter so then there's
even another fraction that is like 0.8
to 0.9 times that and that's the number
that I go by right which is that's
really the like USDA recommendation
right or it's it's like 0.7 grams per
kilogram I think is what they recommend
yeah yeah so I'm not sure exactly what
it what it translates to in kilograms I
always go by pounds right me too yeah
unfortunately were American and I get
this asked this question asked so much
online and I give the answer in pounds
and they're like well okay I guess I'll
go convert it but but all right so so so
I just put it like flat out like I weigh
a hundred and eighty pounds right now I
keep my protein at like a hundred and
fifty grams uh-huh
whether in bulking shredding 150 still
long maybe yeah maybe a hundred and like
sixty like
somewhere around there so that's a
typical bodybuilder is taking in about
twice that yeah now more than twice that
because I go by lean body mass so a lot
of people calculate it by just total
mass uh-huh and how did you arrive at
that and why have you decided that
that's what's optimal for you so there's
there's a clinical study out there that
references I don't know the reference
the exact reference but there's quite a
few out there that show that you know
after a certain point it doesn't benefit
you anymore so I figured why not like
find out where that like I'll use that
as a reference and just kind of find out
what works best for me so like I said I
do like a lot of data analysis tracking
and optimization so there's like certain
body scans you can do to track like how
much your total mass is and how much of
that is muscle mass so when you're in a
deficit like a caloric deficit trying to
lead up to a show means you have to eat
less than what your maintenance calories
are so you're gonna lose weight so you
want to do that as optimal as possible
because you don't want to sacrifice the
hard-earned muscle that you just spent
the offseason trying to gain so it
doesn't make sense to build up two
pounds of muscle just to lose two pounds
of muscle before a show so there's
there's a balance point there that you
have to kind of hover around and like
different scans like DEXA scans will
tell you how much muscle mass you have
in body scans measures like resistance
muscle impedance or impedance and we'll
translate that to how much muscle mass
you have on your body what your bone
density is so I track that and basically
if I'm losing more muscle than what I
want as I'm cutting down for a show I'll
kind of like increase my my protein a
little bit because that's not the goal
like I want to maintain that muscle and
like hold on to it and lose the body fat
so I just kind of use that as kind of
like nutrition is different for
everybody
I can tell you exactly my number
somebody out there can go follow it they
won't see the same results because
everybody responds differently so that's
kind of where I just use you know trial
and error right gotcha and what is the
relationship between sourcing your
protein from whole foods versus
supplements supplements are always going
to be a little bit more processed so
different doctors out there - Colin
Campbell for one of them will tell you
that you know when it's more processed
an isolate
in its isolated form your body doesn't
necessarily absorb it as efficiently so
it's always better to get the whole food
source because it contains other
chemicals that will help your body
absorb that that vitamin or mineral or
whatever so that's kind of where it led
me to maybe I'll just go more whole food
plant-based and see if if I see a
difference and it's the same so I just
kind of shifted all my like like more
alternative meat style of nutrition to
more whole food plant-based so that just
means that I have to eat more carbs more
beans more lentils all this stuff and I
love eating a little bit more tofu and
tempeh which I love as well and you see
the same results right and you're in a
sport that is terrified of carbs yeah so
what's the what's the relationship to
carbs and how do you you know think
about the the low carb no carb craze and
you know how there's a lot of talk about
ketogenic diets and all different kinds
of new ways of avoiding carbohydrates in
your diet as a means of optimizing
performance yeah I mean just from like a
basic nutrition point of view like carbs
or our energy source right so it doesn't
really make sense to cut those all out
there are times when you can manipulate
carbs to your advantage but you don't
have to like you don't have to cut out
carbs like very much so people in the
fitness industry or carbon phobic so
they refuse it's like anything that says
carbs in it they're like nah I can't
touch it and anything has protein in it
they're like I'll give me more so my
approach is like first like optimize how
much protein you need right figure that
out first
not people don't even have any clue they
say you're vegan but what about wood
like where do you get your protein how
do you get enough protein and I ask them
like huh how much do I need and they're
like and how do you find out how much
you need protein yeah how would you
optimize that for yourself like if
someone's listening to this they're fit
they go to the gym whatever like how
would they figure that out yeah I just
kind of explained it so like the figure
out your total mass figure out your body
fat percentage or an estimated body fat
percentage calculate your lean body mass
and then get about point eight to 0.9
times that so if you a
you know if you have a hundred pounds of
lean body mass get about 80 to 90 grams
of protein and just kind of use that as
like a reference like you something it's
not the perfect solution because it's
way around like within that scale and
see yeah yeah exactly
and then the next thing you can do is
calculate your fat percentage so
normally I get about I don't maybe 20 25
percent of calories from fat and then
the rest I just leave two carbs so that
leaves me with like 50 to 60% of my diet
comes from carbs and when you say car I
mean carbs can be anything right carbs
can be coca-cola and potato chips right
so you say car if you're talking about
what specifically I'm talking about like
whole food carbs not highly processed
sugary white bread or like I stay away
from all that I don't even include oil
into my diet either pretty cleaned I eat
a lot of potatoes a lot of beans lentils
legumes rice oatmeal cereals granola all
those things contain carbs a lot a lot
of green veggies like a lot like people
like you can only see my fridge I go
through like a 10 ounce bag of shredded
cabbage like I eat like three or four of
those a day just because like I use that
as like a foundation for like my Big
Buddha bowls that I make so I eat quite
a bit of like green veggies too so
you're getting a lot of micronutrients
which help your body recover quicker
right so the carbs that you're consuming
or whole food plant-based and they
contain other additional properties that
help you perform better right and what
about supplements other than protein so
my supplement protocol is pretty
straightforward I'm a skeptic when it
comes to a lot of supplements I don't
believe that people people put too much
trust in marketing and not enough
investigation in the evidence well it's
a multi-billion dollar industry that
that is completely unregulated yeah and
preys on people's fears and lack of
understanding and knowledge I think
that's kind of how we came to this point
right of like the protein myth in the
car befo BIA and all these things so
it's like the more they can push
something to for you to consume or to
buy then the better it is for them but
they're not necessarily looking out for
your your hell
they're looking out for their pockets so
I'm a big skeptic when it comes to
anything I'll just like you tell me
something I'll take it at face value
then I'll go take a look and see what I
can find for myself like trust but
verify essentially and I was like a huge
engineering thing that everybody used to
say trust but verify
dude like measure twice and cut once
right that kind of thing so same thing
goes with supplements there are certain
supplements out there that work some
that are complete phony [ __ ] you're
just buying expensive urine as a doctor
con would say you know you ingest all
the supplements and all you're doing is
pissing it out and I so I take protein
I'll take B CAS I'll take vitamin d3
PCAs in addition to protein yeah what
are those doing for you
so basically DCA's for those that are
listening or like essential amino acids
so some of them we get from our diet
some of them we have to consume through
food and if you take BCA's during your
workout you can prevent like if you
completely deplete yourself from your
energy source so normal that happens
like I know different depends on your
intensity but if you run out of fuel
you'll start pulling energy from
elsewhere so most the time that comes
from muscle so if you have BCA's in your
system when you workout or when you do
something that requires a lot of
endurance then it can prevent that a
little bit so that's why I take BCA is
not necessarily because I'm trying to
build muscle I'm just trying to maintain
what I already have with that and I'll
take d3 which I think everybody should
take d3 if you go get a blood test
you're probably a little bit deficient
in a lot of people probably the majority
of people are vitamin D deficient yeah
same thing with b12 so I take b12 as
well which we can't really get in a lot
large quantity from plant foods and I
take DHA and EPA mm-hmm so that's more
of your long long chain fatty acids
right and there are those from like an
algae source yeah yeah they're they're
derived from algae so those are like my
four or five main things I take creatine
as like every now and then creatine is
another lake synthesized supplement
doesn't come from animals it's very
easily available as cheap and the
science backs up its claims
I mean don't expect to be mr. Olympia by
taking creatine but it does work so it
will help with performance help with
Durin's strength explosiveness that type
of thing so I'll take a cake
occasionally creatine but yeah is there
a harm to taking that long-term honestly
I don't know I think everything in
moderation that's like the key when you
do anything it's like you don't want to
rely on anything it's like even like
I'll go up I'll go like a week or so
without taking any protein shakes I'll
take a look at my diet and see what I
can include that I haven't been eating
that I've been getting from like a
multivitamin you know so it's like it's
about balance are you doing do you do
regular blood work yeah yeah I do I do
so I think that's another thing that
most people don't do they they say that
you know they feel crappy and they blame
it on all these other factors but they
don't necessarily know why they're
feeling crappy and getting blood work is
one of the most right easy ways to
identify what's wrong what's going on
right yeah so we referenced earlier that
the more successful you get and every
kind of hurdle that you overcome you
know in your mind makes you makes you
more bulletproof to you know the the
voice of dissent but also there's going
to be the people who are like yeah but
yeah but yeah but right so I can't let
you go without asking about the steroids
because you're in a culture in which
that is that's look it's ubiquitous
right so I'm sure there are people out
there like well he's not eating animal
products but he's but he's doing
steroids right so where do you come down
on all of this there's there's a lot of
people say that there's videos about it
there's like I mean you name it there's
articles there's like it's the Internet
right remember that so just remember
that everything on the internet isn't
true you're right you don't know who
wrote it so it's it's a sad truth that
society has set the bar so low about
what's possible and what's not so I get
accused of it daily you know I even I
think I blocked the word on my Instagram
because it was just like every other
comment was that and I was like I'm sick
of hearing it you know not here to
defend myself to anybody I'm here to
talk about the benefits of this diet you
know I mean like if you don't believe me
it's not my job to convince you then
like I'll just keep on living my life
and talking about what I want to talk
about but the the issue there is that
people have set the bar so
though about what's possible and what's
not possible naturally and they think
that they are doing like justice by
accusing somebody of taking steroids and
don't get me wrong a lot of guys do a
lot of guys that are listening probably
don't know that a lot of guys they know
we're doing steroids because just
because you do steroids doesn't mean
that you're gonna blow up like it's
always about the hard work it's always
about the diet it's always about
sacrifice and effort right
supplementation all this other crap is
it accounts for this much if you don't
have this huge pyramid you can't get
like this is the amount that supplements
accounts for so that bar has been set so
low and people are so easily accusing
other people of doing it that it
perpetuates that thought and the person
but below that reading saying like oh
yeah you only got this way because of
steroids like now and that person thinks
that that is the only way that you can
get that way but they've never tried it
they don't know their limitations like
how could you possibly know your
limitations if you never pushed yourself
to your limitations and know how far
that bar really is and I'm the type of
guy like I pride myself on work I pride
myself on work ethic I pride myself on
optimizing things it's like I'm very
analytical data-driven so I find out
what works and I apply it and there's so
much room for growth when you optimize
your nutrition and you optimize your
your exercise protocol your exercise
programs so many people don't do that
they think that they're gonna take a
magic pill take magic juice or whatever
and they can get there without doing all
the hard work that comes before it so my
answer is like it's really easy to judge
somebody based off of a photo or one
picture you don't know me you know you
don't know where I come from you could
look at me and never ever assume that
I'm a white art and Tinian Hindu right
like you don't know my story so how
could somebody possibly know someone
from one photo or one video when 99% of
the time that person doesn't even know
who they are
right so it's like I've accepted it like
I've just come to terms with it it's an
argument I'll never win
doesn't matter what I
you will never convince anybody but it's
just a sad reality that these people
think it's impossible but they've
already exposed the limitations of their
own mindset because they don't believe
it's possible for them so it definitely
can't be possible for anybody else
well it's certainly more comfortable to
dismiss someone like yourself as a
cheater because then it makes it easier
to you for you to feel okay about not
putting yourself out there you know I
mean like and that's unfortunately a
human quality it is it is uh yeah and
you know I I think it's it's a weird
thing because you are in a sport where
like it's rife with that and you see
these guys that have these physiques
that you just know it's just it's it's
perhaps not physically possible for them
to look that way without some kind of
enhancement I see pictures of you and
you look unbelievable but it's not like
otherworldly mm-hmm like it looks like
it's within the realm of possibility you
know what I mean like it's different
from some of those other guys so you
know III I believe you I take you at
face value with that and I trust that
you're you're telling me the truth and I
appreciate your willingness to talk
about it because it's got to be a
sensitive thing for you especially when
you make this decision to put yourself
out on social media and you have this
cause that you believe in and you're
trying to kind of expand people's
consciousness and awareness and then you
know you have to be on the receiving end
of that but I guess that's look it just
goes with the territory
and a part of this world and that's just
part of it as well
mm-hmm it's understandable to like I
don't get mad I used to get mad because
I was like hey come on like I did it the
right way like you're trying to detract
or slander my name or and say that it's
like I'm a cheater or whatever else and
like nothing against guys who do I know
so many guys who do it and great people
and it's just like me and my personal
values this is like I don't want to
sacrifice my long-term health for
short-term goals short-term benefits
like that's logically one of the reasons
why I'm vegan you know because I'm
looking ahead to the future like I want
to live a long healthy life then spend
time with my grandchildren have like be
able to be active when I'm that age
not be relying on all kind of
prescriptions and everything so yeah who
is that guy
the bodybuilder youtuber guy that he
just passed away rich Piana piano I
don't know much about that story but he
died of a heart attack or something like
that or heart fell or was it drugs or
was it I don't know I don't know I met
him a couple times and he was actually
like a really cool guy like nothing
against anything his personal choices or
his personal choices I don't know
exactly what happened there but you
can't help but wonder if that played a
part you know to it so like I said if
there's any guys out there that are
considering do it just know that there's
so much more room for you to optimize
and different avenues like in approaches
you haven't tried yet so just don't go
resort to that you know because you
worked out for a week and you didn't see
any results like you haven't working out
for like ten years you know and you only
see you only have met me in my path in
life at this moment but you didn't see
me flanked way back when when I was just
like you you know it takes time but
anything that's like worth it takes time
and if you're passionate about it you
can sustain it you know you can get
there just taste how bad do you want it
most people want it but they don't want
to give up drinking you know they say oh
I work out I go to the gym I eat right
but then you take a diet of like a
deeper look and they're out partying
every weekend you know they they're not
willing to put into work so how are your
parents doing with all this where are
they they're not part they're not on the
community more right no they don't live
actually they're going back so so they
they live in New Orleans right across
the street from the temple in New
Orleans yeah and they actually bought
land back in Mississippi so they're
going back they're going back Wow yeah
yeah they went they went full circle too
because and they like left it and now
they're like getting older they want to
go back and just live like a peaceful
life minimalistic and just yeah yes and
what do they think of this this whole
world that you're in
they they they all they're like my
number one fan you know they don't
understand it as I don't expect them to
I try to keep my mom in the loop as much
as possible and she's all like
great honey like you're doing so many
amazing things and I love her for it
like she doesn't have to know like all I
just need her support that's the only
thing I need but they they embrace it
and they're very proud of Who I am and
especially now the fact that I'm like
being more vocal about my background
because that's something that they
really wanted to instill in me so now
the fact that I'm talking about it more
openly on the show like this they're
just gonna eat it up
and it's cool how you've taken what you
intuitive like what you learned as a
young person you know as part of that
community and and made it your own in a
different way and and now you're
translating it or sort of conveying the
ethos like the spirit of all of those
values are being channeled in a modern
way that can connect with a young
audience mm-hmm it's not couched in
Hinduism or hymns or any of these things
it's couched in things that are
relatable to you know an 18 year old kid
who just wants to you know go to the gym
and get stronger and didn't realize when
he clicked on your video or looked at
your Instagram that he's also going to
get blasted with the spiritual message
but you do it in a very graceful like
roundabout way where it doesn't it
doesn't feel like that that's what's
happening but you're kind of elevating
awareness well you're providing these
people with what they think they want on
a surface level if that makes sense you
are 100 percent right like I'm very
I guess mindful of how I talk about
certain things especially when it comes
to spirituality comes a any ethical
conversation anything about politics I
mean they're all very touchy subjects
for people so I wanted to appeal to the
younger generation and just develop a
new sense of consciousness because I
feel like certain things come in
different phases right if you developed
a consciousness first like I had then
it's very easy to follow this lifestyle
but if you come into it for another
reason maybe the more vanity perspective
then eventually those thoughts kind of
come over time so what do you mean like
we're all
where I am I doing this well we're all
connected with our actions and our
thoughts right one directly affects the
other so initially people might think
that hey I need meat I need it to look
good that's just the way it is right I
need to I don't like killing animals and
stuff like that but it's just the way it
is so then I keep living that life but
if you come into it and just say hey
I'll just change my actions I will just
stop eating meat just to look good then
the thoughts start to develop because
they're directly related to each other
and say maybe I didn't need it and wait
a minute why is it this way and they
develop a new sense of consciousness and
then like the back of funny stories like
some of these guys that you would never
ever ever in a million years consider
them to be like ever try going vegan
some of those guys are like posting like
animal rights videos and stuff nowadays
so it's like guys back in from the gym
in Bakersfield
yeah a couple of them yeah so it's like
wow like I never pushed that on anybody
you know I just pushed the health
message just because I feel like that's
the foot in the door that's most like a
common denominator across the board that
people want to look better and feel
better
this is your way like this is an
approach you know may becoming trendy
now it's been around for a while but it
may become more mainstream now but it's
been around for a long time so if you
try it you know maybe the consciousness
will develop over time and I'm not
saying that people aren't conscious I'm
just saying they don't know what they
don't know mm-hmm what do you think is
the biggest myth or misunderstanding
about you and about bodybuilding in
general based upon what you've learned
man I can I can be a pretty
misunderstood person yeah from like
people not yet I think we don't correct
well we talked about the steroid thing
but yeah there's other things I mean
like I still expect that after this
episode I mean as I've done yeah many
interviews and stuff and like I'll
expect it till the day I stop doing this
but I don't know I mean it goes by
anything just maybe just don't judge a
book by its cover
you know like I may come across as a
person that's vain or post shirtless
photos and
whatever whatever but it's all a
strategy to get you to read a caption
that maybe change your life to help you
you know so it's like if you know
there's so many people out there that
are willing to judge other people and
it's just like I come from a big place
of judgment so it's really easy for me
to look past it and deflect it and just
kind of understand that's how people are
they journey like you have a lifetime of
it yeah being judged yeah this is
nothing yeah so it's almost like I was
groomed for this you know to be like
stand strong and my beliefs and
everything and be a beacon of light for
people and just be willing to take the
shots you know but it's about
understanding people as well and just
understanding that people judge
something they don't know same way that
I was judged when I was a little kid and
the way I was raised and it's okay you
know you just have to approach them and
help them understand so that's what I'm
trying to do I'm not trying to convince
anybody to go vegan like because I want
them to go vegan or anything like that
it's like I'm just trying to help you
like I just want you to feel as good as
I feel mm-hmm you know and if you know
if you put all this stuff aside as ego
and these like paradigms then maybe you
can experience a different version of
life that you never anticipated so it's
just where I'm at
yeah man I think that's a good place to
wrap it up how much are you uh how much
are you training right now I train daily
like I said it's mine that's my
meditation if I heard you say somewhere
like 45 minutes in the gym right like I
have this decision like I used to live
on marine Street around the corner from
Gold's Gym and I would go to Gold's Gym
and then you know over I've lived in Los
Angeles like 20 years and every Blue
Moon I'll pop in over there and it's
like the same guys it's 9:00 to 5:00 it
is the same people I've been going there
for 30 years and they look the same and
they're litter it's like they check in
in the morning and they're there they're
there like all day long yeah the same
like sort of aging bodybuilder crew yeah
female bodybuilders and the like I
always say it's like a mix between like
a prison yard and a porn set
you know but then when I heard you say
like look if you can't get it done in 45
minutes like you're not focused
essentially it's what it has like even
when I was working as an engineer people
thought I was a professional bodybuilder
full-time they had no idea you know like
I talk about that for that reason is
that like yeah but it's easy because you
have all the time in the world to spend
three hours in the gym I don't have that
because I have a job and all this stuff
and I'm like wait wait a minute like I
was an engineer for you know five years
and I lived that same lifestyle and all
you need is an hour a day you know like
that is about like it's not like like
endurance training I guess like where
you have to go like like more times than
equals so much better you know I'm
saying like there's a certain limit
there where you can't break down anymore
you just you become useless at that
point so there's no point in working out
two hours when you know an hour and a
half of it you're on your phone
bullshitting talking to people and just
kind of spinning your wheels like that's
the reason why you're not seeing results
bro like cuz you talk all day you know
if you go in there with 45 minutes to an
hour and really put in the work you walk
out of there like crawl out of there
like that's why like spend a day with
like your gym buddy and then spend a day
with me or spend a day with another
professional bodybuilder and you'll
understand why they look that way you
know people think that just by being in
the gym you're gonna get results it's a
whole industry build upon that idea very
much so very much so so you only need an
hour max yeah you know but then think
about this is that you're outside of the
gym 23 hours which one do you think
holds more weight for building muscle
you know like yeah you break down in the
gym but you build outside of the gym
your daily habits outside of the gym
hold way more value than what you do
inside of the gym so if you can get your
diet right you get your daily habits
right get everything kind of just you
ducks in a row mm-hmm then the results
will really start to come in so that's
what I'm talking about the extra growth
and different aspects of people's lives
mm-hmm and where are you on the whole
like low weight high rep low rep highway
like are you like how does all that work
like I don't know anything about that
stuff oh man there's so many different
there's different theories right oh yeah
you talk to one person it's one thing
you talk to another
another thing I'm a big believer in
periodization training so you follow
something for an extended amount of time
eventually you'll plateau because your
body's so adaptive and it responds like
more efficiently the next time you do it
diminishing returns to go to shake it up
you gotta shake it up so I follow things
for about four weeks at a time and
sometimes I'll go in and do a completely
new set of training routines just to
kind of help create that shock value to
my body so it'll help stimulate it to
grow in another area because the more
you work out the harder it is to figure
out these new ways to stimulate your
body so sometimes I'll do a high rep low
weight sometimes I'll do the low weight
high rep or did I say that right yeah
yeah the opposite right so heavier with
lower reps or lighter with higher reps
there's many different people that will
tell you that works there you can do a
traditional bro split a bro splits like
a five day workout split where you go
like just not where you get mad at your
buddy that's a different kind of youlet
that's a bro rake up that's right break
you know which does create bodybuilders
- yeah so you know your five-day split
would be like chest on Monday back on
Tuesday take a rest day legs on on
Thursday arms on Friday so it's like an
isolation style workout yeah yeah then
you have like your upper lower crowd
which likes to do upper body one day
lower body the next day take a rest date
upper body lower body take a rest day
then you have people to do push-pull
where it's like you do all pushing
movement so you do chest triceps done
it's very affect all of them work all of
them have their own uses it's like I
tell people like same thing with
nutrition you have a toolbox and you
have different tools for different
purposes if you use the wrong tool for
the job you're not going to get the
right result so same thing with keto
same thing with you know the low-carb
thing or high carb thing like it's all
like relative to what that specific
point in time is when your fitness
journey right I like it man all right
parting words somebody's listening to
this they're like all right I'm
motivated I'm going to the gym he might
tell me what to do what's the one thing
I should do what's the one thing I
should eat everybody wants to distill it
down into that you know little box that
you can check
but if you could impart like some sense
of wisdom or empowerment for somebody
who's just trying to like get a little
bit fit or eat a little bit healthier
perhaps believe in themselves a little
bit more so it's a few different nuggets
I got for these this crowd first thing
is that you can't outwork a bad diet
remember that get your diet in in check
first then worry about working out when
you go to the gym go with intention and
go with a plan you have a checklist just
just by doing the checklist you're doing
more than what you would have done if
you're just wandering around number
three be intentional
yeah exactly walk into the gym with
intention and like you're clocking into
a you clocking in to work I get the work
done and then worry about your other
stuff later number three would be focus
on the bigger picture it's so many I get
so many questions about what about meal
timing what about if I eat this on in
breakfast instead of lunch or eat too
many carbs at dinner like think about
the big picture like first worry about
how much you should be eating and just
choose a 24 hour period and make sure
you eat that much in the day then break
it down and say like how like the new
next target would be like how many grams
of protein you're needing and they just
focus on the big things like it's like
the 80/20 rule mm-hmm like if 20 percent
of your effort gives you 80% of the
results focus on that don't worry about
the extra the extra detail that's not
going to give you or yield the most
results with the amount of effort that
you're putting in so the the 20% that's
gonna give you the biggest results is
like I said fix your diet
second thing go in a gym with intention
third thing would be consistency just be
consistent just be consistent there's no
secret formula that's not sexy though
it's not and people don't want to hear
it but it's it's the reality and you
know there's a reason why the guy in the
gym that has been going to the gym for
years like you say and they look the
exact same is because they've been going
into the gym and doing the same [ __ ]
exercise they've been doing the last 10
years and they've been eating the same
exact way they've been eating the last
10 years you know like they're
consistent but they're consistent in the
wrong approach
so like fix
certain problems first and then you
start to see results Klein NIEM I was
awesome man yeah thanks for talking to
me beautiful super inspiring I'm really
excited for the next chapter that's soon
gonna be unfolding I think when
game-changers comes out you know it's
gonna it's gonna strike a major chord
and it's gonna put you in another
stratosphere in terms of public
awareness and it's beautiful that you're
carrying this mantle and trying to help
people man so anything I can do to help
you I think it's fantastic Thank You Man
I really do appreciate that and I'm
ready ready for the next chapter yeah or
is there a competition coming up there
was a few this year that I kind of
started prepping for I did three this
year back to back to back and just kind
of got I needed to focus more on my
business and write everything else so
it's like it's really tough to juggle
bodybuilding prep and traveling and
speaking at events and then trying to
start up a business and do that so it's
decided to take a little break are you
uh you have any speaking things coming
up like is that on the vegan Fitness
website or on your Instagram or worship
people go - yeah definitely my Instagram
I'm probably the most active so you just
find me my underscore Delgado so that's
and I I do you have other score did
somebody take your name no I feel like I
have a unique name so people always
botch it okay so before it was just me
my Delgado but they app people were like
what am I looking at like they couldn't
distinguish for the first and last
you've started so I had to put the
underscore in there uh and then vegan
Fitness comm is gonna be a really
exciting website for people to go it's
gonna essentially be like an online
resource for anybody that is interested
and the plant-based lifestyle from an
evidence-based perspective yeah that's
exciting that's very cool yeah and you
got the Generation V podcast recently
launched yeah check that out yeah
Generation V has been an exciting
exciting project I like it a lot better
than YouTube and that whole platform
yeah it's cool it's a you know you could
breathe you know yeah you get to know
people you get to really share a story
beautiful thing yeah like it and
instagrams really instant instant
gratification right podcast you're in
their ear you're talking they get to
know you as a person and I feel like
that's more
Vinson in a picture for sure all right
ma'am piece implants we did it how do
you feel I feel good man you good yeah I
could go for another two hours
all right yeah we went to ten man we
rocked it awesome uh thank you so much
come back anytime and talk to me man
thanks man appreciate each other all
right peace
[Music]
you